e
e e
[Music]
Christian
good
evening welcome
welcome we're glad you're here my name
is cat and my pronouns are she
her we have a couple of announcements
and then we'll get started with our
worship
if you are interested in being baptized
we will offer a baptism class after the
service on December the 8th 15th and
January 5th it will be a fairly short
class about 20 or 30 minutes the
baptisms will occur during the service
on Sunday January the 12th sign up for
the class by scanning the QR
code because of scheduling challenges
we're going to to do our Christmas Eve
service here on Sunday December 22nd it
will be a familyfriendly service where
the kiddos will stay with us Nursery
will be available we'll sing Christmas
carols like candles all the things we
normally do to celebrate this special
season so mark your calendars for Sunday
December 22nd for our annual or for our
special Christmas Eve on not Christmas
Eve service
these candles
lit are a sign of the presence of Christ
Among Us fully Divine and fully
[Music]
human please stand as you're willing and
able as we come into our time of
[Music]
worship gracious God
in the midst of the busyness of
life we pause to enter into your
presence quiet our hearts and Minds as
we seek you in this moment of
Stillness speak to us Lord and help us
feel your peace that surpasses all
understanding may this time of worship
be a sanctuary of rest
for our
souls may love find
you find
us may we all come
[Music]
home thanks so much
Kev well we are going to get started
tonight with A Christmas Carol as we are
entered we are already in our Advent
season um and if you've ever played
music for you know that Carols can
sometimes be the most challenging music
to play as they always seem to have a
different chord structure and um it can
sort of be a nemesis sometimes as a
musician but let's sink into this one
tonight and um pay attention to the
words and just enjoy the joy of this
season as we prepare to welcome a God
who is with us who is present to us here
on Earth
[Music]
sing
Angels Angels We Have on high sweetly
singing all the L and the the mountains
in
reply echoing their Joy
[Music]
St Earth in ex Shel he day
shephers why this
ju why your joyous St go long what the
gladom tidings be which Inspire your
heav song oh
[Music]
in ex shallel be stay oh
Lord in
Exel
[Music]
day day
[Applause]
[Music]
oh see him in a
maires of Angel's praise Mary Joseph L
your while our hearts in love we raise
[Music]
oh
oh in Exel he
ve need shy day oh
[Music]
oh chel
day all right judah's leading the way
kiddos so you guys can follow him out
and your teachers are going to meet you
over there thank you so much kids
ministry team for helping our kid out
tonight hope you guys have a great time
[Music]
together and we are going to transition
into the prayers of the people so if you
are with us for the first time tonight
um we just invite you to follow along on
the screen and read the parts that are
in red aloud and then we will pause for
a moment for you to lift up anything
that might be on your heart that you're
caring into this space and just name it
out loud if it's a person or a situation
just speak that out loud and then um
we'll close out the prayer together at
the
end Jesus for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
in my mother's
WB you form me with your hands known in
Love by
you before I took a breath when I doubt
it my I'm wonderfully made you're in
arst the part of the can and
the you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for Your
Glory before your
[Music]
name there's a healing
light just beyond
the walk through
fire I see feeling now I know nothing
has been wasted no
fure
AR the
[Music]
king you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
[Music]
glory for your name you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work together
For Your
Glory and for your
[Music]
name for your
name when I doubt it Lord remind me how
wonderfully made you're an artist and a
part
I'm the can and the clay and I know
nothing has been wasted no fail or
mistake you're an arst and a part I'm
the C and the clay when I doubt it Lord
remind how wonderful made
you're and part the camp and the I know
nothing has been wasted no
failure you're in AR is
the the
[Music]
[Applause]
C you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me
yeah you're not finished with me you're
not finished with me you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me you're not
finish with me yet if you make all
things wor
together for my future
and for my good make all
the work
together for your
glory and for your name I doubt Lord
Mighty how wonderfully made you're in
Hest
[Music]
the and I'm going up has been
wasted feel your own
mistake is stand
upon
stand you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work together
your
glory for your
[Music]
name
together for my
future for my goody make
all work
together for your
[Music]
glory for your
name I know sometimes when you're in the
middle of a struggle singing a song like
that can
feel honestly for me at times it can
feel painful and dishonest
because sometimes in the middle of the
struggle it almost feels uh easy to
believe the lifee that God needed you to
go through this pain that he's the one
orchestrating the
pain so that you can become something
[Music]
better and I just want to encourage you
tonight as we stand in this room
together a collaboration of stories
and pasts and
presents where things don't always go
the way you want them to where prayers
don't always get
answered the way that you wanted them
to that this scripture this song that we
just
sang is not meant to insult you but it's
meant to give us a hope that no matter
what we Face we do not face it alone
because there's an author and a
perfector of our faith who is doing a
deep work in each one of us and he has
not given up on that
story that story is still being
[Music]
completed and he sees each one of us as
a work of
art not the person we're going to be in
the future but the person that we are
right now today with all of our BL
punishes and all of our pains and all of
our mistakes and all of our sins and our
struggles and our
hurts God sees you and he loves
you he is the one leading us forward he
is our
[Music]
Gyra so whether you're in the middle of
the storm or you're on the other side
able to
say he is doing a good work he has done
a good work regardless of where you're
at tonight let's hold on to that truth
that he is with
us he is
[Music]
Emmanuel I'll never
be I am right now wasn't holding you up
so there's nothing I can do let you
down it doesn't take a trophy
to make you
proud I'll never be more I
am going a but
I I hear your voice carried in the of
the wind me
out you would cross an ocean so I
wouldn't d
you never closer you
are you
are you are
now and I will be
content in every
circumstance you are
you are
enough forever enough always enough more
than
[Music]
enough I don't want to
forget how I feel right now on the
mountain
top I can see so clear what it's all
about
stay by
my When the Sun
Goes
don't feel right
now you are
[Music]
enough you are
enough I will be content
every
circumstance you
[Music]
are
already I'm already
chosen I know who I
am I know what you've
spoken I'm already
love
[Music]
IM let's sing that again together I'm
already I'm already
chosen I know who I
am know what you
spoken I'm already
love more than I could
[Music]
imag is
enough one more time I'm already
love I'm already
chosen I know who I
am I know what you
spoken I'm already
love more than I could
imagine God Is
[Music]
Enough see that is
[Applause]
enough that's enough that is
enough that is
enough that
[Music]
you
are you are
enough you are
enough and I will be
content every circumstance
[Music]
you
are God we stand on that
tonight that we were loved before we
took our first
breath that you have seen our story from
its beginning and you are not through
with
it that you are with us in our
storms that you walk beside us in our V
Valley and God if we don't have the
perspective of the Mountaintop tonight I
pray that we would still feel you just
as
close just as
present because you came to walk with
us you came to hold the pieces of our
world in your
hands and we believe God that your love
can see us
through that your love restores and
redeems that it makes beauty from
[Music]
ashes Gyra you are enough would you help
that to be true for
us help us to believe that and to live
that way
in Jesus name
amen all right I invite you guys to turn
to the people around you and say hello
before our speaker comes up
hey how about that Bas player tonight
guys this was Jessica's first night with
us on base and it was such a gift so
just had to say that real quick
sorry
agreed um that's not the only first
that's happening tonight um I agree it's
so awesome having you on the team
Jessica but also we have our first time
to get to hear from a guest speaker who
actually runs in a very similar vein as
we do here at the table Gwen you want to
come on up this is is it officially
gelin Lou when only when I write it yeah
it's just quw well come on up um when is
the pastor and founder I guess you would
say of GRA house mckenny and their
tagline is all means all so that tells
you just a little bit about who she is
um I have had the privilege of sitting
with her in a couple of breakout
sessions and um we did
a allies Clinic I don't know a better
term for it where I was first met you in
person um together last year at the
table and that was my first introduction
to Gwen and the thing that struck me the
most is the questions she
asks I really feel like it immediately
told me gwy is a listener she wants to
hear people's stories she wants to know
how can I advocate for you and that's in
the back of her mind at all times and
that came through just in a clinic that
we were in but the other thing I will
say just from following her on the
socials is I know enough about Gwen to
know that anything that she's doing in
Ministry today came at a great price and
you can trust that she's never going to
offer up anything cheap because she's
paid dearly for the ministry that she
does every day in and day out and that
for me is enough right there um because
you know you can take it to the bank and
um she's given up some leadership roles
and some backing and um and has moved
into a space um
where you know there's a old chorus that
runs through my head that's more of you
and less of me and I can say her her
life is speaking that testimony like God
I want more of your work on the earth
even if that means that my platform gets
diminished and um I pray that her
platform only grows from here and um but
that's because I know that her heart is
for the least of these and um so I just
want to pray over her it is such an
honor to have you here tonight and thank
you Brett's been on a silent treat um so
that's he's not with us tonight because
if he was we would all just sit here
together Sil um but which isn't a bad
thing it's not a bad thing it's not um
but anyways let's pray for Gwen if you
guys um would pray with
me God I thank you for the gift um that
gwy brings with her but I also thank you
for the gift of who she is beyond
anything that she has to offer um us
here tonight God I thank you for um the
Deep work that you've done in her and
the Refiner's Fire that she's walked
through so that um what comes out of her
is pure gold and I'm grateful for that
and Lord I ask that we would have Open
Hearts and open ears to what you're
doing here among us and what you're
saying tonight through her and um we
give this time to you and thank you for
it in Jesus name we pray
amen you thank you so much that is High
Praise wow um I had intended to just
jump into a bunch of stuff but before we
do that I feel after that beautiful
introduction and the spirit leading to
give you a little insight before I just
jump into business and a little
vulnerability that I would rather pull
out my teeth than do but I see it down
there and so I'm going to honor your
convictions and values with my own and
that is I was raised in a faith system
my family is badly broken and
beautifully Blended um but the faith
system I grew up in didn't have room for
a me I my pronouns are she and her but I
was told I was a bad girl because I
asked boy questions as a kid so I always
grew up thinking that my Essential self
was either disappointing to God
rebellion in some way or I was wrong
somehow and God was so sweet in finding
that I had an older brother who taught
me to read when he was learning how to
read and books became my lifeline and
then I was introduced to the theater
where I could be someone else and in the
safety of someone else's skin I found
myself but then there came a day where I
didn't know who I was unless I was
performing as someone
else and that gets really dangerous when
I was married at the time my Destin is
back there with me and we have now a
16-year-old and a 13-year-old so while I
say we've been married for 21 years 17
of those are redeemed because the first
two were playing house the next two were
the seventh circle of hell in refining
as we learned what it meant to actually
be human and then to actually be human
in community with one another and I we
were part of a church plant that we were
a part of for 21 years it went from 40
people to I think at Christmas there's
like 8,000 people that come through the
doors of like 17
Services where I was an actor at first
and then I was um on the women 's
teaching team and I was like but you
know I'm a girl right and they're like
yes and I was like okay I'll teach I
guess and someone called out a gift of
knowledge which I didn't know was a
thing or that girls could have it but I
kind of stepped into this potential
identity that has opened up the whole
world for me and growing up in the
theater people were people were people I
come from very unhealthy heterosexual
parents and a gay theater director told
me that what was different about me was
God's thumb print on my life that I was
responsible to Steward and so I had this
weird I loved Jesus but the church
didn't really have a place for me and
the theater did and the theater had a
bunch of people that would never go to
the church so I was in like these two
communities straddled trying to figure
out my place and it was about two years
ago ago that a beloved family member
came to me and said I want you to be the
one to tell the family that I'm in
heaven because I can't reconcile gay and
God and it's better if I go to heaven
now then hate myself on Earth or I live
out my life now in honesty and I go to
conscious eternal
torment when I say I was flipping tables
in the temple at the church I was I was
I could no longer follow with Integrity
the idea that some people could be
welcomed and not affirmed as humans that
their love isn't recognized as holy that
didn't make sense to me and I could no
longer stay on staff or really worship
amongst these people that were my family
and my friends of choice when my own
family of blood couldn't or wouldn't
support support me in doing that you
know it's it's interesting when you
speak out in truth you find out who your
friends
are there are a lot of people that
silently supported
me and that man in the back my dtin
stood tall in Hell on my behalf he was
like I don't even get the whole thing
but I love people and I love you and I
trust what God is doing in and through
you and we started a journey together
and in January a year and a half ago we
started meeting with some friends and
praying about what do we do and I called
all 83 churches in mcken to see if there
was a non-denominational expression of
an open and affirming church and I found
out in all of Colin County you are it
you're it yay for you yay for you being
here and taking a stand and a step
towards the inclusion of the kingdom of
God when we miss out on some of the
stories we miss out on the face of God
every story is sacred and every story
matters and there wasn't a place where I
could go in McKenna unless I wanted to
be a Mainline denomination and I
couldn't get behind Victorious living so
I couldn't be Methodist and I couldn't
get behind the way sovereignty was under
explained so I couldn't be a
presbyterian so I didn't know what to do
and so we started praying and I am an
accidental Church planter there just was
no one else doing it and I said well
I've I've been dissin I was kind of the
DTs mascot more than I was like their
ideal student per se and I got called a
heretic twice which my husband thinks is
just hysterically funny um because God
Is Bigger to me than I was taught or
others understood or were comfortable
with and so Grace house Community Church
was born and Grace house is convinced
that all means all and we live under the
belief that God made all God loves all
God wants relationship with all and God
sent Jesus to make that relationship
possible for all because all means all
and we exist to help all people
experience not just the sufficient love
of Jesus that says you can attend and
you can even give but you can't serve
out of your giftedness and you can't
have real community that and so often it
is within community and service that we
find who God made us to be and and so we
help all people experience the
extravagant love of Jesus that makes all
things new that we are New Creations it
doesn't mean I'm not the Gwen that
always was but in where' you go your
beautiful prayer for me I had beloved
tattooed on me after some jaw surgeries
and I couldn't speak for quite some time
time they cut all the muscles in my face
and had to reattach them I have 32
screws four uh plates and two prosthetic
jaw joints and when it's cold and wet
anyone with artificial joints knows it's
not the best idea and I was like God if
I can't speak for you who am I if I
don't use my gifts to serve you and I
fought hard to be to find sure footing I
know who I am I know what you've spoken
in this place right now in front of
people as a girl and trying to figure
out what that means biblically and
biblically I have come to these
conclusions that I am beloved capital B
before I am anything else as are you and
we will never come across someone else
whom God does not love that God does not
want relationship with and if I'm so
confused about who I am existentially
how in the world do I know who you are
unless you tell me and so stories are
sacred for me being an actor you could
never play someone honestly unless you
had compassion for them and so putting
on the shoes of other people and The
Human Condition and what it means to be
flawed and human and yet God to have an
answer in Jesus was always a huge thing
for me so I go actor but I was going to
be divorced theater teacher because all
I did was teach all day rehearse all
afternoon grade papers all evening and
that kept me really busy so that I
didn't really have to engage my husband
and so then I became a Humanity student
and then that led somehow to
Seminary and and then it led to uh
residency leadership and different
leadership roles in the church and now I
find myself here and I'm just a little
girl from Oklahoma who's trying to be
friends with Jesus and love people and
and yet God continues to write this
amazing story that if you read it to me
as a kid I never would have
believed I never would have believed
that God would a want me or B use me for
his glory and the good of the world and
so that's why I stand here a a redeemed
prodigal daughter in the glorious love
of Jesus Christ and I have a passion one
of my things in grad school is hity I
love critical thinking I love the idea
of I'm not going to say something and
I'm certainly not going to sing it if I
don't agree with it there are some songs
at our previous church that we would
sing and I would be like la la song song
song
nope la la la song song song because I
didn't agree with one line and Dustin's
like yeah but you're leading so you kind
of have to sing along I'm like so what I
began to do is I began as a as a
preacher to start critically thinking
about the things we say we
profess and if we only read people that
agree with us we will read very little
and if we only um give in to whatever
the newest and latest thing is we will
have no roots Ephesians 4 we will be
tossed back and forth so how can we have
a deep and wide learning and build
Bridges with people that are different
how can we understand with compassion
and
curiosity so that we can learn in any
scenario and so what we're going to do
tonight is we're going to look
critically at some Christmas carols
primarily the one we just sang Angels We
Have Heard On High at Grace house we are
walking through Advent which was
explained to me in college because I was
like I'm not Roman Catholic we don't
really do that and they're like there
are a lot of Protestants that do it too
and it became like this beautiful thing
and it's the lights have gone down but
the curtain has not come up yet it is
this anticipation
of the Emmanuel promise and then I
learned Emmanuel with an e is Latin
Emanuel with an i is Greek okay didn't
know that I just thought people were
confused and it bothered me so you're
welcome so um this idea of advent is the
idea of
anticipation of of preparing for the
birth of Jesus and what Emmanuel God
With Us really means and so there are
four weeks and you can see like this
candle
labra I don't know why I had to roll
that but it was pretty fun for me so um
this candle labra over here there are
three purple candles a pink candle and
the white candle purple purple pink
purple white that's the order okay the
first one is all about the prophets this
is our Old Testament candle and it was
all about Hope believing that God would
be who he says he is it is this
conviction not just wishing but
believing enough to act on the idea that
God will make all thing right in the end
that love in the words of Ann Lamont
love bats last okay this week we are in
the Bethlehem candle which is the peace
candle the second purple candle and it
makes me giggle because there's very
little about the Christmas season that I
find
peaceful and when I think about the
Nativity Story I think there's very
little about the ity story that was
peaceful I've given birth twice never in
a stable and it was not very
peaceful you know and then they put this
like writhing human on you and they're
like okay have good have luck good job
go go and you're like okay and that
wasn't very peaceful and now they're 16
and 13 and it is not very peaceful but
this idea that the Prince of Peace has
entered the world peace is not reliant
on our circumstances peace is a
supernatural gift of the holy spirit
that we experience in spite of our
circumstances and for me it's one of the
most powerful Evangelical tools that
Christians have the idea of being
peaceful especially in your own skin in
a world that tells you you're
wrong so next week is the shepherd's
candle sometimes sometimes it's red I
love when it's pink it's a little happy
in the middle of there and it is
Shepherds were the
unclean they were the low people that
were never ceremonially clean enough to
join worship and so God brings worship
to them and the angels appear to the
Shepherds and they not only believe the
message they respond to the message and
then share the message which is what
we're going to talk about tonight then
the the last purple candle is the
Angel's candle and we usually do this
like that Sunday before Christmas week
and then finally the Christ Candle is
the white candle in the middle for like
Christmas day but on our Advent candle
holder at home the middle sinks down a
little bit so my 16-year-old when she
was probably N9 or 10 comes down the
stairs for Christmas and goes who's
Chris because we had this Chris candle
lit so the middle white candle in our
house is the Chris candle but it is
actually the Christ
Candle and so as we are looking at Grace
house oh yes all right history lesson
but it's fun I promise I am in plaid
combat boots I will not bore you with
history but I want you to know that
people that ignore history think that
their situation is so strange and new
and and crazy when it's just history the
pendulum will swing all sorts of ways
and when we are surprised or shocked by
it it's sometimes our own fault by not
knowing our own story all right so we're
going to start over on this side and
over on this side Pagan winter solstice
festivals that's hard to say especially
with surgery face have gone on since
before recorded history they were in in
the Viking World they were the Ule log
all of those things are part of this
winter solstice the shortest days the
darkest days having light and hope in
the midst of them was a big theme okay
so now we're going to come over this
way and in 125 ad now the idea of Gloria
in exelis Deo which means glory to God
in the highest was as old this
Christianity itself it is it is shouted
out at Jesus as he's coming down on Palm
Sunday the Mount of Olives and they say
glory to God in the highest Hosanna
Hosanna that means heavy Glory when
money was not paper money something was
valuable it was heavy so the word Glory
means heavy glory to God in the highest
the the the bishop there were five of
them at the time
the bishop of Rome decides that sometime
in the winter which spoiler alert he was
probably born in the spring but but you
know what romanticize all you want Jesus
December off we go so Nativity
celebrations they were required for the
monasteries and this is something to
remember especially as this
church when the capital c Church can't
or won't represent Jesus well
there is always a
Remnant God will preserve something of
his heart for all people and at this
time during the when Christianity was
illegal these monasteries would have
underground services and they would
whisper to one another Gloria in
excelsius Deo which is Latin for Glory
to God in the highest and that was the
Angel's Hy which is the refrain of
Angels We Have Heard On High okay so I
was over here and then I got excited and
went over there too early okay so now
we're going to come over here
Constantine think what you will about
Constantine whether he was really a
Believer or deathbed confessional or all
of the weird things but he decides
everyone's been worshiping on different
days let us pick one I think December
25th sounds really nice and we are going
to call all of these masses for the
Nativity the Christ Mass and Christmas
is born Okay so we've got now Christian
ity will be declared legal and then the
religion of the Empire and that's when
it's going to start to swing because
conversion at sword point is no
conversion at all okay so we're going to
come back over to bad news toown and I'm
mayor of bad news toown right now over
the next 800 years the only place where
you would hear Christian themes was in
the church it was in Latin that nobody
understood and it was in plain song that
nobody enjoyed and so the monks held
Christmas and the common person had no
expression in the church okay so then
we're going to start to swing over here
and St Francis of Ace is a cool dude he
should be Saint something for all sorts
of reasons but one of the things he does
is in the Dark Ages when it was Latin
and plain song and nobody was a part of
it and nobody understood he brought back
the medieval plays and he would start
Nativity pageants and he would create
songs that were actually local drinking
Tunes but he would write new words to
them so that people could learn them
quickly and easily and so then all of a
sudden children are starting to get
involved with these Christmas pageants
and it goes from St princess of aisi is
Italian yes goes to Spain and France and
into England and no I'm still over here
okay I'm sorry I moved that was my bad
okay I'm still over here in goodtown so
St Francis of a we've got these pageant
songs and the church says
no all of a sudden now the carols aren't
always biblically accurate they're to
drinking songs the regular common person
is getting into it and they're like oh
oh what's going on I'm feeling nervous
my hula hoop is rattling and people take
it and run this is when we start getting
now bring us our figgy pudding which was
in England churches would bar their
doors on Christmas Day because drunken
riots would go around to some of the
houses demanding money and food and if
you didn't give it to them a they
wouldn't leave and B they're likely to
loot your house
so it became this scary debauchery time
where some of the churches would close
their doors and a few of them remained
open and said I don't care if you're
hung over come on I don't care if you
don't know anything you're just getting
out of the cold it's warm in here come
on those churches were primarily in
Germany okay so languages everyone can
sing people are into it it starts to
devolve we're back in bad Tex
okay so now the far religious right the
Puritans of England are actually going
to cancel Christmas there is actually a
Grinch that stole
Christmas okay under Oliver Cromwell
Christmas is
cancelled
okay because it got too far out of
control we don't say what it is it's not
biblically accurate we're
done and Germany is like I'm I'm not
done and there are the Industrial
Revolution the Industrial Revolution is
Raging this is when eight and nine
yearolds are going to work 15 hours a
day six days a week it is if you've
heard the Charles Dickens um A Christmas
Carol Scrooge was the common mindset of
the day all right that kind of Ideal is
what's going on in the industrial
revolution okay
four events bring back Christmas and I'm
going to see if I can try to remember
them because I left my notes at home so
we may just get a strong three but if I
can remember all four here we go the
first one is an American Minister writes
a
poem and we know it is TW the Night
Before
Christmas it was the idea that St
Nicholas would come and visit that he
was a real person who would visit
children and bless them we all need
blessing one of the other things that
happened
is George Frederick handle was born in
Germany and in late 1700s he would write
Messiah and all of a sudden the church
would get really confused because the
Christmas carols are theologically
accurate and beautiful and now they
don't know what to do with them Martin
Luther before he he fell in love with
the Carol movement and one so many
people to protestantism by using
drinking songs with with German language
of Christ and people were like I can do
that and so all of these things and then
we get um princess Victoria or Queen
Victoria marries the prince of Albert of
Germany and he brings in back this
family ideal of and now all of a sudden
Santa family we get rise of 17th century
Victorian carols most of the ones we
know are from then and then I think
that's the last one yes the 1900s peace
seems impossible in the world we've got
World War I we've got World War II we've
got all of these World conflicts and the
Christmas carols themselves have
ceasefires on Christmas day so that
soldiers can sing to one another and
there's like this trench warfare
ceasefire in World War I okay so
Christmas caroling becomes this way of
encouraging in a dark time and in a dark
world so what does Christmas mean to you
what is it is it a time of debauchery is
a time to remember they were baptized at
Epiphany which is the 12 Days of
Christmas and then the wise men actually
showed up probably 18 months to two
years later and they saw the Infant
Jesus not the baby but
again I don't want to wreck your
Christmas so um is it a time to remember
what Emmanuel means is it just about
festivities and hustle and bustle why
would we call this peace so let's look
at the hair or Angels We Have Heard On
High yes carols of Christmas I'm getting
all antsy and excited and um going too
long so Angels We Have Heard On High yes
and
yes Angels We Have Heard On High sweetly
singing they spoke look it up Luke 2 and
the mountains in reply Echo we've got
heaven and earth singing Gloria in
excelsus Deo Sansa
2 Shepherds this is now going to the
Shepherds that heard the message like
why are you singing why your joyous
strengths prolong why are you not only
singing you're singing like crazy people
what the what the which makes me giggle
glad some Tidings be why are you singing
what are you doing and what's going on
this is the most powerful evangelism
that there is is when your life looks
different in the world because of Jesus
Christ when the love and the peace and
the joy in your life regardless of
circumstances is shown to other people
they get curious Gloria in xelis Deo
stanza 3 Come to Bethlehem so not only
do they hear it they're inviting us Come
to Bethlehem and see Christ whose birth
the Angels Sing adore on bended knee
this is what you did to royalty you
never looked royalty in the eye you
always bent if you ever get to go to
Israel when it's Jerusalem when it's not
war torn and you go up to the Temple
Mount there's a little step and a long
step a little step and a long step
because you cannot run up them you must
go slow and you must have your head
bowed it was an architectural way of
humil humity and going into the temple
come Ador On Bended KN Christ the lord
the newborn king Gloria in excelsius Deo
and then
four see him in a Manger lay Jesus Lord
of headen I love when we apostrophize
things and I just got to say
apostrophized which is great and Earth
Mary Joseph lend your Aid this does not
mean a Band-Aid or a cold ice pack it
means sing with us with us sing our
savior's birth let's all sing together
if all doesn't mean all we are lying to
ourselves and up to no good all means
all Gloria in eelus Deo and that is the
story of this song we don't know the
author we don't know the composer but we
certainly know the message it is as old
as Christianity itself it is the reason
that Jesus came Gloria in Nelis
D and as we transition to communion and
as we we look at this opportunity to
partake in the family
meal we say Gloria in exelis Deo would
you say that with me Gloria in exelis
Deo glory to God in the highest and on
Earth peace and Good Will to all
people um there's a I skipped the whole
end of it so that we can go ahead and
move into communion and there was a
something I was supposed to read that um
is back in McKenna and so there is
apparently a slide and it's got Fort I
think front row goes first red is wine I
don't remember what the O and the T are
Jesus is our Good Shepherd Moses was a
Shepherd first Covenant David was a
Shepherd introduces the New Covenant
Jesus is our Good
Shepherd and he Institutes the second
Covenant that's my
cue and we are going
to yes okay so the whole heart of this
whole thing is all means all this table
is not my invitation it is the
invitation of the Lord who made you who
loves you who knows you and wants
relationship with you if you do not know
a relationship that is filled with love
joy peace patience kindness goodness
faithfulness gentleness and self-control
talk to one of the leaders here who
would bend over backwards to help you
find what that relationship can look
like in your life and in your context if
you have been away from the church for a
while away from Christian Community for
a while it is costly to come back it
takes courage to come back and say I
have not given up because the god that
made you has not given up on you and
he's not given up on your Birthright to
have Christian Community with one
another this is a family meal and if you
have walked with the Lord for quite some
time and it is time to go deeper for you
whether that is a step forward or even a
step back don't shoot me volunteer teams
if it's a step forward or a step back so
that you cannot miss this don't miss
this when my kids were born a mother
figure in my life said Gwen don't miss
this it's a hustle and a bustle and a
lot of stuff and
flurry don't miss it be present what do
you need today to be present and not
miss this Gloria
inis um the
communion is going to
happen I'm going to pray and then we'll
figure out what happens then there's
bread and juice and wine one's white
one's red I think and you know we're
just
Jesus when all else fails Jesus when all
is going well Jesus when we don't know
what to do Jesus when we are so sure of
ourselves that we've got everything
planned
out
Jesus you have come to be one with us
we are told that in this world we will
have trouble so when we are surprised or
shocked by trouble it's so crazy to me
how often I get surprised and shocked
when the world doesn't go my way and
then there's a big old but but take
Heart Take courage for I have overcome
the
world this meal this communion meal is
brought to us through your body
and your blood one broken for us one
shed for the Forgiveness of our sins
Lord we Revel in the truth of your
sacrifice frees us to be truly
human let us be human with you and with
one another
today we don't have to be afraid of it
because you're not we don't have to be
afraid of what we see in the mirror
afraid of who introduce ourselves and
how we introduce ourselves to other
people because you are not we are
beloved first foremost and
always thank you for this symbol of what
that means and it's in your name Jesus
that we pray amen
[Music]
Body of Christ broken for
you body of CH for
you body Christ brok for
you body CHR
[Music]
what
for
[Music]
would you guys go ahead and stand again
with us and we're going to wrap up
tonight with that Carol that we talked
about um so grateful for Gwen's message
and let's just enjoy these lyrics with
our New Perspective and um the blessing
of Christ being with us and inviting us
into this story
[Music]
together sing
glor in shall
St GL
oh
oh in ex shall he
[Music]
see him
in whom the choirs of Ang praise Mary
Joseph L
your while our hearts in love
we
oh oh
in
[Music]
Exel
oh in
Exel oh
[Music]
in a chel
day thank you so much for joining us
this evening thank you to Pastor Gwen
what a wonderful insightful message that
was about the Inc coming Christmas and
Advent
season thank you also those of you that
joined us
online we appreciate that we hope that
you have a blessed week as
well thank you so much for joining us
this evening and if you are new we would
like for you to fill out a card at the
table on your way out or you can scan
the QR code of this visitor's card
generosity is a key aspect of life of
adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the table at theable tx.org
we can all use more relational support
and spiritual connection the way we do
that at the table is through our
meetups if you are not yet part of a
Meetup please scan the QR code to find
out one that works for
you all right I would like to send you
into your week with this
blessing you can hold out your hands in
a posture to receive or just open your
heart to these
words you are a child of
God
you are a child of God
this is
true on your worst
day and this is true on your best
day so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact
with be
blessed have a good week and we hope to
see you back here next Sunday
[Music]
oh in Exel
he oh
[Music]